all right let's start so what do you
guys feel like women don't understand
about men and what don't men understand
about women are you asking us
okay
I'm Gonna Let You Go guys go first oh
that's so kind of you to let me go first
I'm a gentleman
okay what do women not understand about
men and what do men not understand about
women who you put me on the spot Anton
um
yeah you could start with you could
start with um
what men don't understand about women
because you know okay what men don't
understand about women
don't we go first yeah okay
I think women don't understand about
women is and a lot of the conversations
are about like security and being a
provider and I think a lot of men don't
realize how important emotional like
security and safety is
um I think they think about it as like
I'm protecting you like physically or
I'm gonna take care of you with income
but I think taking care of somebody's
mind and soul is just important I think
a lot of women value that
um what women don't understand about men
I think women read into what men say and
do too much instead of just taking it
it's like for what it is like straight
value men are pretty straightforward
they tell you who they are they show you
with their actions and a lot of women
will read into that like it's something
else or try to prove like oh I can get
them to change you know
but do you think that men care about
what women think or what it is that they
care about because we slot women right
like we slot women based off of what we
need them for versus what women think
that we need them for right so we slot
women for example it's the ones that
we'll have sex with or we'll bust down
and then it's the ones that we'll take
seriously and will marry though right so
are all women the same as far as that
emotional connection that they feel like
that they need with a man in order for
them to really really feel like they're
connected
I think that there's a huge disconnect
with everyone emotionally so I think
that with a lot of women
have that expectation of what they want
emotionally
um
wait what was the question do you think
that guys really
take seriously like because you say that
what men don't understand about women
but I'm not I'm not sure that men don't
understand that because we we understand
the emotional connection is important
right like even when it comes to sex
right that emotional connection is what
heightens the experience right
absolutely but then at the same time
in a lot of instances we really just
don't care
I think what a lot of the conversations
that women have or they're like looking
for men to care or have at least like a
basic understanding and compassion of it
and moving to in a way that I think both
sides need to
make sacrifices to help their partner
and I think that's one of them I think
there's a time and place when you know
maybe your feelings are too much and men
are like I don't care about that but I
think to completely disregard a woman's
emotions also
there's a there'll be an issue in the
relationship there you think so
I'm not focused on what a woman thinks
or what she cares about
or what she wants I'm 100 focused on me
and it's her responsibility to be
focused on me
so if your wife came to you with an
emotional problem would you disregard
her like upfront or would you listen to
her at all like what give me an example
um say she was feeling insecure in the
relationship and she felt like she
wasn't getting enough security maybe she
thought your eye was wandering and she
was a little bit nervous about it what
would you do to comfort her or would you
just why would she be nervous about that
the nature of a guy
is to look at other women
if you understand that then that's not
something you should be insecure about
okay I think a lot of times
you just fixed it unfortunately I'm not
as lucky as your wife to find somebody
else
she's very fortunate did you say if
you're if your wife saw that your eye is
wandering and she's worried about that
um then
then how would he react to that yeah how
would he reassure her and then you're
saying Anton that if your wife saw your
eye wandering she should not be worried
about that I think that the thing about
it is just that if you want a
relationship you understand that
you're not the only woman on the face of
the Earth right so when she says
wandering oh my God okay I'm sorry I
actually thought like a medical I wander
yeah
I was like wait a minute
she has a lazy eye and she's like can
you please out of nowhere yeah okay
yeah but I mean if if you saying
wandering you know you got to be dive a
little bit more into it right is it just
is it looking at another girl or
whatever or is it no I think people
should like I think everyone looks at
other people it's what you do with
what's the actions you take Okay so
let's say that was a bad example let's
say you a girl's in your DM she's
sliding in the DMS and you're responding
to her you're sending her nudes
did you get any tips on how to send one
yourself
as attorneys we're privy to we can enter
into a process called Discovery where I
can ask for let's say three to five
years of your taxes your bank statements
but I can also get your DMs I can get
your tweets I can get your emails uh we
also hire private detectives and they'll
follow you around and they'll get
photographs of you and we get a lot of
information there's a lot of infidelity
going on
um Facebook actually changed the game
all the divorce attorneys remember when
Facebook really hit because you had
people reuniting uh with their old high
school sweethearts and high school
flings and colleges I mean Facebook was
only best things that ever happened to
divorce attorneys because we would walk
in before social media yeah because we
would walk into court with just stacks
of iems instant messages holy [ __ ] and
confessing all of what they were doing
for the past three months and oh you got
me pregnant oh I'll pay 500 you got the
whole wife there really oh my God what
if your venmo transactions are public
and your lawyer goes through your venmo
and then you see what [ __ ] he's
sending money to how so if the person
has their Instagram it's like
like they what if they just don't share
their password
you can request that and they they are
obligated uh under Court powers to give
you that information so if you plan on
getting a divorce make sure you plan it
out three to five years ahead of time
you need to plan it out all right
absolutely
so you get a cheating clause in your
prenup a cheating clause in your Arena
that might I mean here's the thing it's
not illegal to cheat anyway right and so
if a cheating clause in your prenup it I
guess it just depends on what the
cheating Clause is going to say
um because people cheat all the time and
sometimes they get punished for it
sometimes they don't so they just I
guess depend on what you want to happen
if your spouse is caught cheating oh I
have a question yeah do you think that
as a divorce attorney can cheating be
overcame in a relationship
question yeah as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible